- [Tim Cook] Introducing Apple Vision Pro.
Vision Pro. Vision Pro.
- Yes, Apple's mixed reality
headset is now a reality.
Here at the company's Cupertino campus,
it just showed off the
long-awaited reality headset.
The face computer, my term not theirs,
bridges virtual reality
where you're fully
transported to a virtual world
with augmented reality,
where you see virtual
objects in your real world.
Apple's calling it-
- Spatial computing.
- [Joanna] And yes, it-
- [Tim Cook] Starts at $3499.
- [Joanna] Apple spent 45
minutes detailing how it works
and what you can do with it.
Let me break it down for
you in way less time.
These are $3 lab goggles.
The headset looks like a pair of aluminum
and glass ski goggles.
Basically these, but cooler
and way more expensive.
The front of the device has a screen
so people can see your eyes
when you're wearing it.
Creepy, kinda.
It looks way slimmer and
lighter than Meta's Quest Pro.
One of the big reasons for that,
a cord from the headset
attaches to this battery pack.
Apple says the battery
will last two hours.
You can also plug it into
an outlet to use it all day.
On the one hand,
I'm excited not to wear
a battery on my head.
On the other hand, battery fanny packs.
There are no controllers
like other VR headsets.
You use your hands to navigate around.
There are multiple
cameras on the device too,
which help you see the real world
with digital objects in it.
The Apple Watch-like digital crown dial
lets you get to the home screen
and also controls how much
of the virtual world you see.
You can even use the cameras
to capture spatial 3D videos and photos.
- [Apple Spokesperson] It's
easy to capture a spatial photo
or video with just the press of a button.
- [Joanna] If you're
wondering how you log in,
iris scans with Optic ID.
Apple says your eye scans
are kept on the device.
So what do you do once
you've got that on your head
and all that other stuff on your body?
Well, Apple showed off a few experiences.
Surprisingly, a lot of the things shown
have to do with work.
You can see multiple windows
from your Mac above your desk.
- [Apple Spokesperson]
Microsoft apps like Excel, Word,
and Teams make full use
of the expansive canvas
and sharp text rendering of Vision Pro.
- [Joanna] You can FaceTime
with family or colleagues.
The FaceTime stuff is pretty crazy.
Since you're not holding a
camera out in front of your face,
you create a scan instead,
basically a hologram,
to appear in your chats.
There's stuff to do in your downtime too,
like watching immersive 3D movies
and playing Apple Arcade games.
There's game controller support too.
But what Apple's really hoping
is that software developers
build new applications
for VisionOS, the operating
system powering it all.
Disney CEO Bob Iger
even showed off some
virtual Disney experiences.
- This platform will allow us
to bring Disney to our fans
in ways that were previously impossible.
- I have a lot of thoughts on it all.
I should be trying it out soon.
Stay tuned for my first impressions.
(gentle music)